in this lesson we're going to look at
alkene reactions that result in
markovnikov addition let's look at the
reaction called hydrohalogenation to see
what this even means we'll start with
this alkene it's unsymmetrical we have
two methyls on this side and just one on
this side if we look at the carbons of
the alkene we can see one two three four
bonds drawn out here and for this one we
only have 3 1 2 3 2 from the double bond
so here we have an implied hydrogen and
when you're starting out with these
reactions I want to encourage you to
always draw in your hydrogen atoms
it may seem cumbersome and take a little
time but is going to prevent you from
making a mistake so let's add in our
hydrogen atom now we're going to react
this with hydrochloric acid and the
ultimate result is that HCl is going to
add across this bond giving this product
now I want you to notice where these
groups added so the chlorine added to
the more substituted side of the bond
where we already had two methyls and the
hydrogen from the HCL added to the side
where we already had a hydrogen atom and
this is the definition of markovnikov
addition we get addition of the hydrogen
to the side that has more hydrogen's to
begin with the less substituted side of
the alkene and the chlorine adds on the
more substituted side we need to look at
a mechanism to see why this occurs
alkenes are nucleophiles they have
electrons in this bond that they can
donate so in the first step what's going
to happen is this double bond is going
to attack the proton of HCl and our
arrow pushing is going to look like this
the alkyne opens up attacking that
hydrogen atom now these electrons will
be left behind
and we'll show them becoming a lone pair
on cl-
now when these electrons come and attack
this hydrogen atom they pull away from
this carbon we're making the new bond on
this side so the electrons are coming
away from here notice we have this
carbon now that only has three bonds and
we're sure of this because we drew out
all our hydrogen atoms through the
process
well carbon is neutral when it has four
bonds and this only has three the
electrons shifted in this direction to
make the new bond leaving this carbon
deficient of electrons so this structure
has a carbo cation right here this carbo
cation is what we call tertiary it's
bonded to three carbon atoms that's
really good for a carbo cation there's a
process an effect called hyper
conjugation that allows the Ch bonds to
stabilize so these CH bonds here to
stabilize this carbo cation we're not
going to go into that in too much detail
but you can google it if you want to
know more and so a tertiary carbo cation
is really stable very good more
substitution allows for more
stabilization of a carbo cation now the
chlorine can come back in and an
electrostatic attraction bonds to this
carbon atom here markovnikov addition is
a specific regio chemical outcome the
chlorine adds to the side that's more
substituted and the hydrogen to the side
that's less substituted but why does it
never flip why don't we get the hydrogen
adding to the other side well we'd have
to imagine the alkene attacking in this
direction opening up in this way and
let's just draw what we would get over
here so here we're envisioning if this
double bond opened in the opposite
direction putting a hydrogen on this
carbon atom here we would get this
intermediate notice this carbon
containing the carbo cation it's bonded
to a hydrogen
and then it's bonded to two other
carbons this is what we call a secondary
carbo cation and we said over here that
these CH bonds are particularly
stabilizing to this carbo cation and
here we have one two three carbons
bonded to the carbo cation this so
called tertiary carbo cation is much
more stable and that's why the bond will
actually open in this direction to
produce this more stable carbo cation so
you can think about this in a couple
ways there's a trick to thinking about
markovnikov addition and that's the rich
get richer and so the carbon that had
more hydrogen atoms gets the hydrogen
atom so always attached to the side that
already had hydrogen atoms and that'll
give you your correct regiochemistry in
your product but this really has to do
with carbo cation stability so if you
want to understand it always make your
more stable carbo cation when you do
your alkene attack okay let's get into
our second reaction for today hydration
we're starting with the same substrate
that we had here
however I've left off all of the implied
hydrogen atoms and I've abbreviated the
carbon as sticks this is a notation that
you're going to have to get used to
these abbreviated structures and so
let's try to look at this mechanism just
using the structure like this but
keeping in mind it's the same structure
as here we're gonna treat this with
sulfuric acid in water and the ultimate
result of this reaction is markovnikov
addition of water across this double
bond so we can see that our Oh H is on
the same side as our chlorine so this is
going to tie right into the mechanism
again and this side now has two hydrogen
atoms notice it's kind of hard to see
this so when you're starting out do
yourself a favor draw out all your
hydrogen atoms it may seem cumbersome
but if it prevents you making a mistake
on an exam it is so worth it okay let's
see why this reaction goes the way it
does looking
at the mechanism I'm just going to show
a proton to represent the proton that
comes off of sulfuric acid and our
alkene is going to open up to form the
more stable carbo cation and attack that
proton so here's our tertiary carbo
cation here's the new proton notice
there's only 1 2 3 bonds to this carbon
so I've left off the other proton for
clarity let's just add that in right now
and now something different is going to
happen here we attacked an acid that has
a nucleophilic conjugate base chlorine
is a nucleophilic atom and so it adds to
the carbo cation but once we take the
proton off h2 so4 and we get hso4 - that
is really resonant stabilized it is not
a nucleophilic acid so sulfuric acid the
conjugate base of sulfuric acid doesn't
add back in instead we have water in
here that's our good nucleophile and
this reaction will be run in water so
there's lots of water around - now
attack this carbo cation water is going
to use one of its two lone pairs to
attack the carbo cation so we're going
to connect this oxygen atom over on this
side now there's something really
important about mechanisms and this is
always going to hold true so I want to
tell you about it right now here we have
something positive a carbo cation it's
interacting with something neutral this
molecule of water whatever comes out of
this reaction has to have an overall +1
formal charge somewhere so if you've
drawn this without a +1 charge you have
a +1 reacting with a neutral this has to
be positive if the thing you've drawn is
not positive you've either drawn it
wrong or you've forgotten to write a
second product of that step and in this
case I had left off the positive charge
on oxygen to make this point to you now
oxygen is neutral when it has it
two lone pairs and then these two bonds
so if we're counting valence electrons
that's 2 4 and 1/2 of these bonds make 6
well when it shares a lone pair it only
has 5 electrons that it owns around it
the lone pair and half of each of these
3 bonds so this is positive and this
truly holds in every mechanism you'll
ever write that if you have a positive
reacting with a neutral you get a
positive a negative with a neutral gives
you a negative so make sure you're
checking every step for your charge
balance now we haven't quite gotten to
the product here because it's charged
then the ultimate product is an alcohol
so our best nucleophile which is still
water the thing that attacked with its
electrons is going to come in and
deprotonate this it's a nucleophile
anything that ever attacks has to have
extra electrons to attack with and so
these electrons will grab this proton
deprotonating it and in every mechanism
where we have electrons left behind we
show them becoming a lone pair on the
atom that they're left on and in this
case we can see how it neutralizes the
positive charge on oxygen and then we
get a neutral molecule out wait a second
I just spent all this time telling you a
positive reacts with a neutral to give a
positive overall well in this case we've
drawn this correctly but there are two
products the hydronium ion is the second
product produced in this reaction and so
we are actually getting two products
from the reaction of a positive with a
neutral and we got a neutral and a
positive out so overall this was plus
one the products are plus one and
everything is right with our mechanism
ok we're going to look at one final
reaction in this lesson this is
oxymercuration and this is going to do
markovnikov addition as well let's start
with our same substrate the ultimate
result is going to be the same alcohol
as we produced up here from the
hydration of this alkene
but this is a really different reaction
with a distinct mechanism let's look at
how it works we first treat this alkene
with mercury acetate in water now the
alkene is going to attack the mercury
and kick off one of the acetate groups
can you guess which direction it opens
up in the rules from here still apply
we're going to attack to form the more
stable carbo cation so the mercury has
added over here we have this carbo
cation for clarity let's add in the
proton here so we don't lose track of
our bond now this intermediate is
special this isn't the whole story with
its structure mercury can actually
donate electrons in stabilizing this
carbo cation this gives another
resonance form for this compound
so imagine mercury shares some electrons
over here we'll get a resonance form
with a mercury bridge now we're just
moving around electrons so since this
was positive the same story with the
steps of a mechanism for resonance
structures applies here and we need a
positive charge in this mercury shared
the electrons and the positive charges
now on mercury this is called a
mercurinium ion and this contributes a
lot to the overall structure however
it's in resonance with this carbo cation
we could actually draw a third resonance
form that puts it in resonance with the
secondary carbo cation but we know that
these two are the main contributing
forms because this one has the positive
charge on mercury and mercury is good at
that this is just a new thing that will
have to learn here but everything we
learned before still holds and this is
our more stable carbo cation so although
this structure contributes when water
attacks it still wants to attack at the
carbon with more positive character so
water attacks
opening up the mercurinium ion and we
actually get this protonated
intermediate but I'm going to cheat and
below my arrow put a minus h plus so
we'll skip the deprotonation step here
and go right to this alcohol and now we
still have mercury stuck on our molecule
but we're going to get a hydrogen atom
here this is a new reaction we can treat
this with sodium borohydride nabh4 in a
second stage of our reaction and the
hydrogen on here is going to replace the
mercury and we get our alcohol resulting
from markovnikov addition over all okay
so why on earth would we ever want to do
this reaction this results in the same
product as acid catalyzed hydration here
and so why bring heavy metals into it
well I have to do a second step with
sodium borohydride why would we do any
of this okay let's look at an example
that shows us when oxymercuration will
be useful imagine we have this substrate
and we want to add water in a
markovnikov fashion across this double
bond on the surface this seems just fine
for acid catalyzed hydration we get the
hydrogen atom adding to the least
substituted end of the double bond the O
H group goes on to the more substituted
side but as you can imagine if I'm
showing you this there's more to the
story than that let's look at the
mechanism and see what actually happens
if we try to do this under acid
catalyzed hydration conditions the first
step is the same our alkene opens up as
normal attacking the proton now we get
the secondary carbo cation now this
secondary carbo cation is next to a
branch now if this hydrogen atom were to
move over with its electrons we can
actually make a tertiary carbo cation
here and this is some of the toughest
stuff that you'll first encounter with
these reactions of alkenes so don't be
discouraged if this is a little bit new
to you right now but since we have the
positive charge here if this hydrogen
moves with its electron
as a hydride h- will show this migration
as these electrons coming right over
here and just for clarity I want to add
on the hydrogen right here on this
carbon and we'll add it here so now we
can see that this has four bonds but
since this moved away with its electrons
it's going to leave a carbo cation here
this one two hydride shift is common in
chemistry and biochemistry and the way
we can spot this is you know I said we
made this secondary carbo cation next to
a branch so we can actually get shift of
a hydrogen or sometimes shift of a
methyl group to give a more stable
carbocation right next door and so you
have to watch out for any sort of
branching next to a carbo cation and if
movement of something can make a more
stable carbocation at the adjacent
position that'll happen under acid
catalyzed conditions so now water
attacks here at the carbo cation we lose
a proton and the product that we get
from this reaction is this so we just
wanted to add water across this double
bond it looks so simple but we had this
complicating rearrangement reaction so
getting back to this question why
oxymercuration it'll actually make this
reaction go with the regiochemistry that
we wanted the O H will just add here
oxymercuration avoids rearrangements the
reason for this is in the mercurinium
ion although we have contribution of
this carbo cation this mercurinium ion
contributes a lot as well this
stabilizes the carbo cation and when
this is more stable it won't want to
rearrange so if we take this alkene
treat it with mercury acetate in water
and then in a second step add sodium
borohydride will produce this alcohol
not resulting from rearrangement so in
this lesson we covered the reactions of
alkenes that result in markovnikov
addition the real reason for the
as we're producing more stable carbo
cations from our initial attack these
all always open up in the same way when
the alkene is attacking something the
addition puts the nucleophilic group at
the more substituted carbon atom in each
of these cases but oxymercuration avoids
carbo cation rearrangements because this
mercurinium ion can form and stabilize
this carbo cation so nothing can
rearrange around it this is kind of a
weird intermediate this three membered
intermediate but this is part one of a
multi-part video series on alkenes and
we're going to see that these bridging
cationic intermediates are very
important in alkyne additions and I hope
you'll join me for the next video